so i just played magnus carlsen at the
opening ceremony of the sink field cup
some of the best players in the world
are in town and they had a slymell
yesterday and the way it worked was each
participant of the steamfield cup played
five challengers and i was lucky enough
to be one of the challengers against
magnus and we had a really fun and
interesting game that you're about to
watch now i decided beforehand that i
was going to give it my all and not play
any dubious stafford gambit or any other
dubious gambits but really try and uh
and give him a fight
and as you'll see it was definitely a
fight and i don't want to spoil the
results but i really hope you enjoy the
video and in a later video i will be
doing a full breakdown analysis of the
game so be sure to subscribe if you want
to check out that
and enjoy the video
bye
this is
me
i should fix that too
i think you're in trouble in this game
how does it look right
in your home
you're wonderful
hello what is your name
nice to meet you my name
i also don't is so is it fun to play
against
no mercy
[Music]
i
[Music]
which position is the most difficult for
you right now
um
[Music]
of course why not so what happened in
that game now did you take the queen
spoke for itself
thank you
sometimes it just be spreads out if you
lose sometimes you win but chess is
always people
[Music]
um
um
foreign
fantastic i'm still feeling
the love of magnus and my students
in a dominant position
work that we do here in st louis and
it's just a gorgeous night so
can i ask you how is it going
for games
the rest of the before
and can you probably make one draw today
i can probably
use two games
[Music]
i don't know i don't know why you're
saying complicated it's really wrong
you play real good on youtube
it comes because it's only the
highlights that are on youtube
which say magnus can we throw rex or
queen over there would that help
is there it's never a queen when you
need one
huh
someone passed rex the queen
you need a queen and they need it now
now
[Music]
look at this
are you trying to put the extra pressure
here
university
i know she's
how are you feeling
i met her number ten
[Music]
okay
um
[Music]
how was this experience
thank you
how many views
um
thank you
what did you finish all these
how did it go
yeah it worked pretty well for me um
yeah thank you so much
not try this at home
can i have this board
yeah
thank you
thank you
thank you
thanks for the game
thanks
i'm sorry no i gotta get around
hey thomas
[Music]
games
it was very nice
uh
magnus can i get here
he's got a simultaneous signing ceremony
thank you
hey april
thank you
where do you want to start now
thank you so much
awesome
[Music]
there you go
thank you
[Music]
hello
[Music]
um